he basically was like get out of your
heads start doing things
and make it happen and it feels great
[Music]
amy ryan robinson how are you doing
great thanks how's it going
wonderful thank you so much for being on
my show i'm very excited to talk to you
about mobility transportation
and you were the vp global at get taxi
israeli-based unicorn and that is a
hugely popular
ride-sharing service but before that you
were also very involved with
waze and move it now most recently the
the chief operations officer of
nemo data but your journey is a little
bit weird
it's not it wasn't obvious that you're
gonna end up
being the ceo of a growing startup or
the vp
at a unicorn you actually started back
in duke and politics so talk to you a
little bit about that
and i'd love to tie in your fun fact of
being
of being a certified yoga instructor
yes so so lots of different elements and
a lot all
together um so yeah so first of all
thank you for having me
um it's really a pleasure to be here and
share a little bit about my journey
um so you're right i started back
um studying politics and economics um
back at duke many many years ago um
and i thought that i wanted to be a
diplomat that was my kind of
first career i grew up in washington dc
um and then at some point i realized
that being a diplomat meant working for
the government which wasn't
suited so well to my personality and i
decided to look for other opportunities
or ways to go abroad
and kind of reached out to some people
at duke ended up working in latin
america
for about four years um how do you get
invented in america
it's not it's not the most obvious path
from israel to duke
to latin america yeah
so so um i went there initially to study
abroad
um i had the choice between spain or
bolivia when i chose bolivia
um kind of the less traveled path um
and after spending some time there i got
connected with some alumni from my
university just to ask them i was really
curious
kind of what are you doing here how are
you doing it um and so from those
conversation
conversations um it ended up turning
into a role for me
um and it grew from there um
so after a couple of years i decided
that i wanted to continue growing in my
career
and do my mba but there was some really
there was a dissonance between
going from latin america back to the us
to do an mba there
um so enter israel during that time i
visited israel for the first time
and startup nation everything exciting
that's going on here
and so i decided to come to israel to do
my mba um
10 years ago and you could say the rest
is is history
yeah so that history is is still very
very long because you've
been an mba consultant for ways and then
you work for move it and get taxi
why why mobility what is it about
mobility that really got you excited
yeah yeah so um during my mba we had
a project where we reached out to an
israeli startup and basically had to
pitch ourselves
um to do a project during our during our
studies
um and so my teammates and i pitched
ourselves to waze
wrote an email to uber levine hi ori
we would love to work for you with you
on any project that you
that you need um and to our delight he
replied
sure um and simple
as simple as that i'm just kind of
you know shooting for what you want and
sometimes
sometimes you surprise yourself so
anyway we became an amazing mentor
um and i think it's really through him
that
first of all that i fell in love with
startups and decided to stay in israel
not only do my mba here
um and also he taught me the difference
between managing
and building and when you go to your mba
a lot of it is about
managing how do you manage your piano
how do you manage how do you control
verses yeah so so i think in startups
um especially in the world again you
asked about mobility why do i like it
why am i into it
um because it's changing because it's
growing it's not managing
something that exists it's building
something that you are imagining
for the future and taking all of the
micro steps now
to make this macro vision a reality
this is something i think that he really
encouraged us to do he basically was
like get out of your heads
start doing things and make it happen
and it feels great
so so yeah so this is how i got into
startups into
uh mobility and through ori i i met the
founders of move it um and yeah
so even with it even within mobility
what what's been your sweet spot what
what has been the area that you've been
really focusing on
yeah yeah so i would say there's kind of
two
aspects to what i what really gets me
excited
um one is like i mentioned
building from scratch to scale so having
this kind of
zoom in zoom out approach of okay what's
the macro vision what's our north star
where are we
aiming for um and then kind of reverse
engineering
all of the little steps that need to be
executed on to get there
so it's not enough to have only the
vision you have to be able to execute on
it and you have to be able to engage
people around it so i'd say
this kind of building from scratch to
scale is something that
if i think of the moments that were like
most exciting or most um
you know when i was in my state of flow
um
it's it's these moments and i think the
other piece of it
is partnerships so a lot of my
um career has focused on partnering with
other
with others to create value both within
the organization
other organizations i'm kind of trying
to figure out how we can get there
together
because we're not going to get there
alone right but but it but still
it sounds to me that the things that you
were mentioning the zoom in zoom out
scale partnerships
that is that is something that is pretty
common too across the board
when you're looking at the tech sector
right no matter really what industry
you're in
you're going to be dependent on and
relying on good partnerships and on
great scale and growth
on any size business so still why
why mobility why helping people get from
point a to point b because i can imagine
you now going to slack or twitter or
google and saying okay we can do the
same thing there
yeah i think there's something really
special about mobility um
i love it obviously
um there's something about the fact that
it affects your daily life
um someone someone
mentioned you know that a good app
should be like a toothbrush you use it
twice a day
um and so i think mobility it's
something that really affects our lives
and affects our quality of our lives
when it comes to your commute how much
time you're spending getting where
you're going
uh these days these cover days it's a
bit uh a bit different
um so how is it changing how is it
evolving but i think that we're seeing
these dramatic dramatic shifts
in something that affects people's daily
lives
a really significant way i mean hours
and hours of every day
are spent moving around of course i
really
get um excited about things that can
really impact
so having having seen a lot of the
different
innovations that have been going on over
the past few years in the space
where are we heading because it feels to
me as more of a bystander that
we have these great tech companies that
are developing these great technologies
to link
drivers and writers even link writers
and writers
but we've reached some point of we've
reached some
you know milestone where okay it's easy
for me to get a taxi no matter what
but but but but i haven't seen really
major advancements in the past
two three years are there big
advancements to look forward to in the
mobility space
sure sure so i think there's kind of two
areas that are exciting to me
um around mobility one is i mean you
mentioned there's lots of different
private companies working individually
and
i'll go back to my my public policy and
also my partnerships
kind of vision to say there's an
ecosystem that is yet to be created
where these systems are working together
and where
it's not um you know there's a place for
the city to be involved there and kind
of what's for the public good
not only know not only am
individual companies with individual
riders but starting to look at the city
as a whole there's this whole concept of
the 15-minute city that i think is
really interesting and really exciting
for the 15-minute city yeah you can get
anywhere in
15 minutes um that's what makes a good
city
um according to this theory so it means
having
goods and services close to you and it
means having accessible transportation
to get where you need to go so
i think it would be great to get
anywhere in 15 minutes
and so i think this is one area that
we're going to see more
more developments that actually help
people
in their lives and i think the second
areas around and this is something
that's really exciting to me
thinking about nemo data is this area of
artificial intelligence
so starting to see not only how we have
the operation
side of these mobility services that
are you know doing a good job today of
offering
rides or offering scooters or whatever
the case may be but then starting to
have this
artificial intelligence that's actually
optimizing things
on a level beyond um so i think that's
something that's really exciting and
there's also
so yeah before even before we talk about
what nemo data actually does
what is the problem that you're
describing here that you you're saying
on one hand we have the operations we're
and we're getting so
we're getting pretty good at them and
matching and doing all the logistical
stuff
what is that layer that we're missing
that you think
yeah yeah so i think that and again it
can be from
everything from scooters to logistics
but there's so much
data that's being generated um
so much data and i'm not talking about
you know michael wakes up here and goes
here i'm not talking about
this and unique data i'm talking about
aggregated kind of on
a macro level there's so much data being
generated
um and it's almost like a tsunami
that that then you know it takes
i think the next phase is to say okay
how what data do we actually need and
how can we use it
to actually bring insights that improve
things um and so i think
when it comes to artificial intelligence
this is where artificial intelligence
can help us
see through the noise or cut through the
noise and and come up with really
smart actionable things to do
to actually take improvements so it's
not it becomes beyond just
moving from point a to point b as an
individual and it becomes okay
how do we optimize the whole system
um right kind of a macro so nemo data is
trying to work on that problem but
and how do you do that so how do you
approach this new market
with this new understanding that a bunch
of this data also
i mean you're coming from a world of
partnerships you need to acquire the
data from these partners
sure sure so um so nema is nemo is
looking at um preventive
maintenance so preventing breakdowns for
fleets and before they actually happen
um so we see a tremendous opportunity
um both in terms of commercial vehicles
like class eight trucks
um that break down they break down a lot
um and it costs a lot
both in the expense of fixing it and
also the revenue that's being missed
when those trucks aren't working
we see shifts to electric vehicles we
see shifts to
autonomous vehicles so all these really
interesting things that are happening
with fleets
and then somebody's gotta prevent them
from actually
breaking down um and and keep make sure
that those fleets are actually running
um and that they're on the road and and
i don't know about you i wouldn't want
to be in an autonomous vehicle that just
stops working and there's no driver to
tell me
no no and there's no driver to you know
keep an eye on
on things it really needs to be um
you know it really needs to be through
artificial intelligence and also with
electric vehicles
nobody's run these vehicles um
constantly you know 24 hours a day
commercial vehicles have all kinds of
stresses on them that we don't know yet
so there's a huge place for artificial
intelligence
to help us take all the sensors
pull the data in compute it and come up
with some actionable insights there i
think what you're saying is fascinating
because i've never even thought of this
i'm think when i think of you know
moving to autonomous vehicles right it's
the it's the
imminent you know future that is
hopefully not too far away
i'm thinking of myself being in a car
and i'm not even worried
that the car will make we'll do an
accident because i trust the autonomous
vehicle more than i trust myself and i'm
a pretty good driver
and i still chose the autonomous vehicle
much more than i trust myself
but i but obviously you know any
machinery anything that
is moving has moving pieces let alone
electricity running through it
is going to break down at some point so
even if that autonomous vehicle breaks
down once every
five years right that's still a scary
thought and i would want
something to be able to tell me to tell
the company operating and by the way
we think in the next few weeks you you
might want to check on on a few things
here
yeah yeah exactly there's definitely a
place for
artificial intelligence to to do the
things in the background that
we as consumers or drivers take for
granted
um you know from your perspective
the vehicle should show up and it should
work and everything that has to do with
preventing
um issues should be happening 100 100
and i'm guessing that until these
solutions come to place
the the obvious solution is going to
have to be regular checkups regular
maintenances
i believe that when i spoke to ghal um
from nemo data he he shared with me
these
astonishing facts about how about truck
breakdowns
across the united states and how much
money is being wasted
in daily monthly annually on on truck
breakdowns that could be prevented
if you would just have that those
sensors that are that are
that are predicting when it's going to
happen yeah yeah there's definitely
major applications for it for this today
um so the figures we've seen are that
there's 85 billion dollars
wasted every year on
um on truck breakdowns that could be
prevented um
both in again those direct costs and the
loss revenue from the vehicle not
working
and that actually those same vehicles
are responsible for five percent
of the u.s greenhouse gas emissions
which is an insane amount
it doesn't have to be you can also
reduce the emissions
by keeping the vehicle in top form um by
changing the parts on time but making
sure that the
tires have the right air culture this
kind of stuff
crazy way so 100 percent and you see
it's fascinating to talk about mobility
but but even more than that i love
hearing your insights along the way so
having gone through these experiences
and now i feel that i've gained a little
bit more insight into the mobility space
and some of the thinking process that
you go through
throughout the years but what are some
things that if you were to look back you
were to tell your younger self even you
know whether it's at a point
in duke or at the mba with waze or move
it wha
what what things would you tell yourself
um yeah yes so i think
i've had definitely a journey with
myself over the last uh
you know 10 15 years of kind of coming
into my own um
coming to myself as a leader i think
that i
you know i don't i'm not usually the um
oldest person in the room i'm sometimes
the only woman in the room
i'm definitely not the loudest one in
the room um
and so it took me a while to start to
understand that those
what makes me different is actually my
superpowers um and that it's not
weaknesses um and to own that i mean i
think i remember
so so clearly during my mba um i studied
with
israelis when i was in this group
of uh you know the israeli guys who'd
been in the military they have their
their kind of leadership style um and i
remember the teacher gave us this
assignment we had like 15 minutes to
work on it and so i you know i said i
read the assignment
and i said to everyone okay what do you
think and what do you think and what's
your input and try to kind of keep us on
time build consensus
and we got to the end of the of the 15
minutes
um and then the teacher says okay so
who's the leader
to present and i saw i turned to the
group and i said who's the leader
and they said to me you're the leader
and it something went off in my mind
that yeah i'm the leader i'm not just
the helper
or the facilitator or you know the
supporter i'm
i'm by engaging everyone by getting that
consensus and
bringing everyone in i'm the leader
and so i kind of went home that day and
said i'm the leader
but it's it's uh
it's it was a journey for me to
understand my style and learn how to use
it and
learn how to use it as a superpower and
and what i love about this story is that
while you while you're explaining the
you know the environment
that where you were bringing bring
together the consensus you
didn't even mention if you even said
your opinion and i think that that's a
that's one of the remarkable aspects of
leadership that
doesn't even necessarily to have the
person who speaks the loudest or is the
first to say their opinion but the
person who is also able to get the
consensus and
and hear everybody and then adapt even
their own views
after hearing everybody and putting it
all together i think that's just
wonderful
amy i i can't believe 20 minutes were
almost up
i really enjoyed this episode thank you
for being on the show and
best of luck with nemo data and and what
you're doing there
i i think it's just phenomenal and i'm
very i'm very hopeful
that by the time that autonomous
vehicles will be here when i'll be in
the vehicle i'll know that it's being
powered
by the preventive analysis of nemo data
but before we leave amy i need to ask
you for three words that you would use
to describe yourself
i'm sure so i think um calm
calm under pressure that's definitely
one
um collaborative i love
working with people bringing people
together um and getting there
getting where we're going together and
curious
i'm really i love learning new things um
and i try to approach
even the hardest hardest things with
curiosity with kind of a
uh a question of
you know what is it gonna feel like when
when we do this amazing thing so uh
yeah and i'm sure it's pretty exciting
moving from a big company like get all
of a sudden to a small early stage
startup that is just getting started
properly
and and and being being in that core
team i'm sure it's a
it's incredible never boring
never born amy thank you very much best
of luck
to gal and and i can't wait to see
nemo powered by nemo date on all the
vehicles
yeah yeah think of us